[Música]
la Corte Penal Internacional emitió una
orden de detención contra el presidente
ruso Vladimir Putin acusado de crímenes
de guerra las autoridades de kiev
celebran la medida y muscula califica de
nula y sin sentido
en Francia la oposición de extrema
derecha de los independientes y de la
izquierda presentaron mociones de
censura contra el gobierno como última
opción para tumbar la impopular reforma
de las pensiones después de que ayer
macron forzara la aprobación de la ley
sin votación en la asamblea nacional una
decisión que ha desatado nuevas
protestas
Turquía aprobará la integración de
Finlandia en la otan antes de las
elecciones turcas de mayo lo anunció el
presidente erdogan reunido en ankara con
su homólogo finés El mandatario Turco
insiste en que el caso de Finlandia es
distinto al de Suecia
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de France 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
más deu y es para mí un gusto
acompañarles abrimos esta edición con
una noticia que ha marcado la actualidad
de hoy Y es que la Corte Penal
Internacional emitió una orden de
detención contra el presidente ruso
Vladimir Putin acusado de crímenes de
guerra por informes de Naciones Unidas
particularmente el tribunal de la haya
sostiene que hay fundamentos para
responsabilizar a Putin de la
deportación ilegal de niños ucranianos a
territorio ruso por eso la orden también
pesa sobre la comisionada rusa por los
derechos de la infancia quien declaró
hace semanas haber adoptado menores del
donbas las reacciones al anuncio han
sido inmediatas el fiscal general de
Ucrania lo calificó de histórico y la
presidencia ucraniana aseguró que sólo
es el principio sin embargo la orden es
a difícil de aplicar si Putin no sale de
Rusia dado que el país no forma parte
del tribunal y Moscú ya declaró que la
medida no tiene sentido y que es
legalmente vacía
la Corte Penal Internacional ha emitido
dos órdenes de arresto en la situación
de Ucrania para Vladimir Putin
presidente de la federación rusa
y para María Elba vale boba comisionada
de la oficina del presidente ruso para
los derechos del niño por presuntos
crímenes de guerra de deportación de
niños de los territorios ocupados de
Ucrania a la federación rusa
consideramos que la misma formulación de
la pregunta es Escandalosa e inaceptable
Rusia como varios estados no reconoce la
jurisdicción de ese tribunal y en
consecuencia cualquier decisión de este
tipo es nula y sin efectos para la
federación rusa desde el punto de vista
de la ley
y Vladimir Putin tendrá miedo ahora de
ir a países que reconocen las decisiones
del tribunal y teóricamente pueden
ejecutarlas
no tengo nada más que agregar sobre ese
tema
previamente analizamos la noticia con
Luis Moreno Ocampo exfiscal de la Corte
Penal Internacional que no se explicó el
funcionamiento de este tribunal y Cómo
aplica al caso de Vladimir Putin
es el único tribunal del mundo que puede
hacer eso porque las Cortes nacionales
no pueden Investigar un presidente
hay inmunidad pero no hay inmunidad para
jefe de estado frente a la Corte
Internacional el tema ahora es como se
resta una Corte Internacional no tiene
una policía global por eso el arresto
depende de los estados nacionales
no puede viajar a Europa no puede viajar
a Colombia no puede dejar América Latina
porque Debería ser arrestado Entonces el
tema es que va a pasar yo creo un buen
ejemplo es lo que con el presidente de
Sudán
intentaba Mostrar que él era inmune que
él viajaba fue a China estuvo escapar de
Sudáfrica porque Sudáfrica los jueces
ordenaron su captura pero básicamente la
comunidad internacional
hizo un acuerdo con bachir donde bachill
hizo concesiones que permitió la
independencia del sur de Sudán
Y entonces por un tiempo no fue
arrestado pero dicen años después un
debilitado presidente de bachiller
sufrió un golpe de estado y está Expreso
Hoy está preso y tan discutiendo con la
Corte Penal Internacional si lo mandan o
no Entonces me parece que un fallo de
esta Corte Penal Internacional tiene un
impacto Más allá de de que aprendo
mañana
muy inteligente tiene que evaluar ahora
cómo maneja este tema Cómo llega una
negociación porque sí él puede lograr
que lo protejan el consejo de seguridad
de Naciones Unidas si hay un acuerdo que
termine con la guerra que termine con
los problemas puede protegerlo al
presidente Putin y suspender suspender
la acción de una corte Así que esta
decisión de la corte si bien es personal
sobre Putin puede transformar la forma
en que estamos manejando el conflicto no
más guerra justicia y discusiones sobre
cómo termina de conflicto y el
presidente chino irá a Rusia la próxima
semana según anunció el Ministerio de
asuntos exteriores de China que calificó
el viaje de visita de paz Esta visita es
la primera de chía su homólogo Vladimir
Putin desde que empezó la invasión de
Ucrania y a pesar de que china lo haya
negado en repetidas ocasiones el medio
político reveló ayer que Beijing ha
mandado a Moscú varios cargamentos de
rifles de asalto drones y chalecos
antibalas unos envíos que habrían sido
realizados vía Turquía y emiratos árabes
Unidos El informes de malbenodman
un encuentro por la amistad y la paz Así
presentó el ministro chino de asuntos
exteriores la visita la próxima semana
del presidente chino a
Moscú
basándose en los principios de no
alineamiento no confrontación y no
ataque a terceros las dos partes
practicarán multilateralismo Genuino
promoverán la democratización de las
relaciones internacionales construirán
un mundo multipolar mejorarán la
gobernanza global y contribuirán al
desarrollo y progreso del mundo china
mantendrá su posición objetiva y justa
sobre la crisis ucraniana y desempeñará
un papel constructivo en la promoción de
las conversaciones de paz el crimen
precisó que los dos líderes discutirán
la cooperación estratégica entre sus
países según algunos especialistas el
mandatario chino que podría también
reunirse con su homólogo ucraniano Busca
posicionarse como facilitador del
diálogo entre kiev y Moscú tras haber
mediado en la reanudación de las
relaciones entre Irán y Arabia
si no quiere encontrar formas de dar la
impresión que esto es parte de una
diplomacia de paz y por supuesto lo más
importante es que lo que no ha estado
dispuesto a hacer que es hablar con el
presidente ucraniano parece que tendrá
lugar después de Esta visita
Por otra parte el anuncio del viaje de
She se produce cuando se ha anunciado la
puesta en marcha del acuerdo entre
Australia Estados Unidos y el Reino
Unido con este pacto conocido como aucus
los tres aliados pretenden aumentar su
poder de disuación y de ataque para
contrarrestar la influencia china en el
mar de China meridional Beijing criticó
por su parte lo que califica como una
política de bloque y de enfrentamiento
entre bandos liderada por Estados Unidos
vamos ahora a Francia porque los
desafíos al gobierno se mantienen dentro
y fuera de las instituciones después de
que ayer Emmanuel macron decidiera
recurrir al artículo de la Constitución
49.3 y forzar así la aprobación de la
impopular Reforma de las pensiones sin
votación en la asamblea nacional en la
oposición la extrema derecha los
independientes y la izquierda
presentaron mociones de censura contra
El Ejecutivo de Elizabeth born que se
votarán en los próximos días la decisión
de macrón también desató protestas de
inmediato que continuaron hoy en varios
puntos del país en la Plaza de la
Concordia de la capital a esta hora
permanecen pequeños grupos de
manifestantes reprimidos por la policía
por otro lado prosigue también la huelga
de recolectores de la basura y este
viernes la alcaldía de París informó que
se acumulan ya Diez mil toneladas de
residuos en la ciudad además el sector
ferroviario refinerías y estudiantes han
anunciado nuevas movilizaciones antes de
la nueva jornada de huelga del próximo
jueves 23 convocada por los sindicatos
todo está subiendo los precios están
subiendo el poder adquisitivo está
cayendo ahora el gobierno quiere subir
la edad de jubilación a los 64 años
mientras muchos jóvenes están en
problemas es mejor dejar que los jóvenes
trabajen y que los de 60 años descansen
ayer prometió la responsabilidad del
gobierno con su cuarenta y nueve punto
tres lo que esperábamos a mediano plazo
ahora mismo muy pronto es que el lunes
la moción de la censura será votada por
una mayoría de los partidos y Finlandia
está un paso más cerca de integrar la
otan Y es que reunidos en ankara el
presidente Turco erdogan y su homólogo
finés sauli anunciaron que Turquía
ratificará la membresía de helsinkey a
la alianza militar antes de las
elecciones generales turcas previstas
para el 14 de mayo Y es que recordemos
que todos los estados miembros de la
otan deben aprobar la entrada de un
nuevo país a la organización y que hasta
ahora Turquía bloqueaba la entrada de
Finlandia básicamente porque la
candidatura finesa iba de la mano de la
sueca y ankara pide a estocolmo que le
extradite 120 personas kurdas que acusa
de terrorismo desde Estambul Adrián
Rocha con los detalles
a partir de ahora con la rectificación
próxima en las próximas semanas de la
entrada de Finlandia la otan los caminos
de Finlandia Yo decía quedarán
completamente separados el presidente
turcos ha explicado delante de su
homólogo finlandés para que tenía muy
buenas palabras las malas palabras
incluso malos deseos que hablaba que
tenía con el Primer Ministro sueco al
que he dicho que es buena persona pero
que no cumple según erdogan con Los
acuerdos que firmaron los tres países
Finlandia Suecia y Turquía en la Cumbre
del verano pasado de la otan en Madrid
sobre todo el don ancha quejado de que
Finlandia no ha deportado a Turquía a
120 supuestos terroristas según Turquía
que el país sanatorio quiere que sean
deportados a su país no lo han hecho
según explicado varias veces la justicia
y el gobierno sueco que estas
deportaciones no pueden pasar porque la
justicia sueca considera que si estas
personas a las que Turquía acusa de ser
terroristas fuesen deportadas hacia
Turquía no recibirían en este país un
juicio justo sin embargo
a partir de ahora Finlandia sí que
entrará en la otra en las próximas
semanas espera después de que el
documento que ha firmado hoy el
presidente Turco respecta y perdón se ha
mandado al parlamento Turco para la
ratificación de este de la entrada de
Finlandia a la alianza atlántica algo se
espera que pasen las próximas semanas
sobre todo porque el parlamento Turco
tendrá que ser disuelto A mediados del
mes que viene mediados de abril para
entrar en la convocatoria electoral que
Turquía tiene prevista para el 14 de
mayo tendremos por lo tanto un plazo de
un mes para que Turquía ratifique la
entrada de Finlandia dentro de la otan y
en España acabó la huelga de médicos de
familia y pediatras en Madrid que
llevaba activa desde noviembre de 2022 Y
es que tras cuatro meses de continuas
marchas manifestaciones y 15 reuniones
con la consejería de salud los
sanitarios y el gobierno madrileño
firmaron en la noche del jueves un
acuerdo que satisface algunas de las
demandas de Los profesionales de la
salud más de en el informe de nuestra
corresponsal Marina Colorado
primer día de cierta normalidad en los
centros de salud de Madrid como este que
tengo a mis espaldas hoy a las 8 de la
mañana se desconvocaba la huelga de
médicos de atención primaria y pediatras
que se mantuvo durante 115 días el
acuerdo firmado entre los responsables
de sanidad de la comunidad de Madrid y
el comité de huelga de Los profesionales
de la salud establece entre otras
medidas un tope al máximo de pacientes
diarios 34 paramédicos y 24 para
pediatras que tendrán Entre 10 y 15
minutos para cada uno de sus pacientes
una rebaja significativa ya que
actualmente las agendas a veces
superaban los 60 pacientes al día por
cada médico además habrá un incremento
salarial de 450 euros mensuales para
todos y bonos de hasta 500 euros
adicionales al mes para quienes cubran
el turno de tarde precisamente los bajos
salarios era una de las principales
quejas entre los sanitarios en Madrid
región de la que el 70% de los médicos
residentes formándose para en atención
primaria querían marcharse por las malas
condiciones laborales Y es que Madrid no
dedica ni el 11% de su presupuesto en
sanidad a la atención primaria cuando la
media nacional está en un 15% una cifra
Por cierto muy por debajo de lo
recomendado por la Organización Mundial
de la Salud que está en un 25% para los
médicos que aseguran estar moderadamente
contentos con este acuerdo este es solo
el primer paso para frenar así la
hemorragia de la sanidad pública
madrileña vamos con información de
América Latina porque el presidente de
Chile Gabriel borich visitó la fosa
común de pisagua en la región de
tarapacá en el norte del país donde tras
el golpe militar de 1973 fueron
enterrados varios perseguidos por la
dictadura el mandatario reivindicó el
plan Nacional de búsqueda de detenidos y
desaparecidos sin embargo borich admitió
que el haber pasado mucho tiempo será
difícil lograr resultados aceptables en
esa tarea y que el éxito es improbable
y hoy se celebra el día de San Patricio
patrón de Irlanda y precisamente por la
gran herencia irlandesa en Estados
Unidos la festividad se celebra a lo
grande en varias ciudades del país en
Chicago el río por ejemplo se volvió a
pintar de verde y en Nueva York el
tradicional desfile volvió a llenar las
calles de Manhattan una tradición que se
celebra desde
1762 el alcalde de la gran manzana
destacó las raíces irlandesas de su
apellido Adams y recordó que la ciudad
fue levantada entre otros por miles de
inmigrantes irlandeses
con estas imágenes llegamos al fin de
esta emisión pero sigan con más
información
[Aplausos]
[Música]